many SUVs are gaining in popularity all
over the world
so now Mazda has presented its contender
for the compact segment the new cx-3 an
apparently successful crossover blending
the Mazda 2 with the bigger cx-5 kunti
have done our test of Montes carotid
start ranting about the pointlessness of
classifications like mini SUV but these
cars are selling so it only makes sense
for a car maker to put their own model
for the class on the market since the
Mazda cx-3 has most of its parts in
common with a supermini Mazda 2 Montes
wonders why the makers called this model
the cx-3 and not the CX 2 the 2-liter
direct-injection gasoline engine puts 88
kilowatts into the front wheel drive or
110 kilowatts into the all-wheel drive
we tested the stronger of the two which
makes the leap from zero to 100 km/h in
eight point seven seconds the average
fuel consumption is rated at six point
four liters per hundred kilometers
Montes points out that this is a bit
unusual nowadays most car makers cut the
capacity down a lot more 2.9 meters one
liter or one point two liters and then
add a turbocharger to make up for the
lost performance but Mazda took a
different route dispensing with a
turbocharger giving the engine a good
sized capacity and highly compressing
the gas mixture in the combustion
chamber to achieve fuel consumption
levels comparable to those of a
turbocharged 1.2 liter engine of the
same performance level Komatsu a liter
motor mid turbo of Flodden
in his Alliance category
like all new model Mazdas the cx-3 s
body is shaped by the koto so emotion
design language evoking the
instantaneous motion scene and living
creatures
clarity and ergonomics guided the
interior design the driver's seat
features a large range of settings and
the cx-3 provides ample leg and shoulder
room Monta says all in all he quite
likes this car the combination of
materials imitation leather not real
leather with carbon elements aluminum
and glossy piano black is more balanced
than he remembers from Mazdas and years
past but in some places he gets the
impression that the workmanship quit
long before the workman did this corner
for example it may be just a detail but
even so and the lining is peeking out
from under the upholstery that could be
improved but on the whole the cx-3 s
interior is quite decent in six tight
Xia Xia ardently a diesel engine is also
available for the cx-3 with or without
all-wheel drive but it's the very low
starting price of seventeen thousand
nine hundred ninety euros for Germany
that will make the Mazda cx-3 tough
competition for the German BMW x1 and
the Audi q3
you